[Музика]
привіт, хлопці, настав час уроку англійської,
мене звати Наталія партитура давайте
почнемо сьогодні, ми продовжуємо розмову про
літературу та читання, тому давайте
почнемо з вірша, тож подивіться та
давайте читати разом, слідкуйте за мною
сьогодні  був найгіршим днем,
і не намагайся переконати мене, що
в кожному дні є щось хороше, тому що
коли ти уважніше придивишся, цей світ
є досить злим місцем, навіть якщо якась
доброта час від часу просвічує
задоволення та щастя  не триває,
і це неправда, що все в
розумі і серці, тому що справжнього щастя
не можна досягти, тільки якщо його
оточення добре, це неправда, що
добро існує Я впевнений, що ви можете погодитися,
що реальність створює моє ставлення, це  все
поза моїм контролем, і ви ніколи за
мільйон років не почуєте, як я кажу, що сьогодні
був дуже хороший день, це дуже
цікавий момент, і тут ви можете побачити
дуже сумне усміхнене обличчя, тому що з
самого першого рядка ви можете зрозуміти  d,
що вірш сумний і гнітючий,
подивіться, сьогодні був абсолютно найгірший день,
а автор цього вірша
насправді дуже сумний, і я б сказав, що
песимістично все погано, нічого не
добре, і ви ніколи за мільйон років не
почуєте, як я говорю сьогодні  був дуже гарний день,
тому з самого початку все масово, а
тепер давайте подивимося на цей вірш
від глухих,
давайте прочитаємо його від кінця
до початку, так знизу
вгору, тож давайте прочитаємо ще раз і слідкуйте за мною
сьогодні  дуже гарний день,
і ви ніколи за мільйон років не почуєте, як
я кажу, що це все поза моїм контролем,
моє ставлення створює реальність Я впевнений,
що ви можете погодитися з тим, що це неправда,
що добро існує лише в тому випадку, якщо одне
оточує хороше справжнє
щастя  досягнуто, тому що все в розумі
і серці, це неправда, що
задоволення і щастя не тривають,
якась доброта час від часу просвічує
, навіть якщо цей світ є
досить злим місцем, тому що коли ви
придивитесь туди ближче  є щось хороше в
кожному дні, і не намагайся переконати мене, що
сьогодні був абсолютно найгірший день,
тому, як ти бачите, у нас зовсім
інша історія,
мені дуже подобається цей вірш, тому що він
залежить від вашого настрою, тому, коли вам
сумно, погода  наприклад, дощ, або у
вас просто поганий настрій, ви читаєте це
зверху вниз, і це
буде як найгірший день, ви будете
песимістично налаштовані, але коли ви почуваєтеся дійсно
добре і щасливі, ви схвильовані і хороші
речі відбуваються  навколо ви читаєте
це знизу вгору по-
іншому, і ви відчуваєте себе дуже позитивно,
ви налаштовані оптимістично, тому я хотів
би попросити вас, давайте подивимося на
склянку з водою, скільки тут води,
вона наполовину заповнена або  напівпорожній
просто glam kenapa livenbaum сірник на
жіночому плакаті Apollo, то що ви бачите
, все залежить від вашого настрою, тож
давайте подивимося на картинку, хто
ви, тож якщо ви скажете, що стакан
наполовину повний, ви налаштовані
бачите хороші речі навколо вас  але
коли ви кажете,
що чашка або стакан наполовину порожній,
ви песимістично налаштовані, ви бачите, що
навколо вас все погано, трапляються лише погані речі
і все негативне, тому
давайте вивчимо ці фрази стакан
наполовину повний, повторюйте за
мною стакан наполовину  -повний і знову
стакан наполовину повний, дякую,
тому якщо я скажу, що стакан наполовину повний,
я оптиміст
, я оптиміст і бачу позитивні
речі, давайте подивимося на цей
стакан, стакан наполовину порожній
раз стакан напівпорожній і знову
стакан напівпорожній я песиміст,
усе навколо мене негативне, і якщо
ви просто бачите склянку з водою, ви,
ймовірно, реаліст, це просто склянка
з водою, і я  Я реаліст, тому
все залежить від вашого настрою, ви можете
бути оптимістом, позитивним мисленням або
песимістом, негативним мисленням або просто
реальністю, ви приймаєте реальність такою, яка вона є, а
оскільки ми говоримо про історії,
все залежить від нашого настрою, і історії
можуть бути  позитивні та негативні, тож давайте
створимо свої власні  розповідь разом давайте
почнемо з цієї
історії різні ми говорили про
драму поезія проза сьогодні ми поговоримо
про розповідь і давайте подивимося
на це тільки дієслова є тут який
час це теперішнє минуле майбутнє так
це минулий час і ми  мати один два
три чотири п'ять шість вісім дев'ять
дієслова давайте поглянемо на них прокинулися
що це означає зламався або сер
надіньте нову вісімку ви залишили це не ліворуч
чи праворуч це дієслово poconos залишити
ліворуч зліва
мав рот прийшов  назад Бабур Нуса дивився,
що махнув сер, грабіжник пішов
Бішофф, так що це дієслова, і
це насправді історія з типового
дня студента, наприклад, або будь-якої іншої
людини, для мене це була історія про
студента, тож можете ви допомогти  я з
історією, я даю вам хвилину подумайте
про історію, яку ви можете створити, використовуючи
ці дієслова
[Музика]
[Музика],
щоб, мабуть, ми могли сказати, що я прокинувся
вранці, я одягнув светр або я одягнув
свій  плаття або я надягаю плащ  це
футболка і шорти чи джинси, я з'їв свій
сніданок або банан, потім пішов на
роботу або пішов до школи, потім я мав
уроки і повернувся додому,
дивився фільм або улюблену кашу чи
мультфільм, а потім зробив домашнє завдання  і
пішов у бій правильно, тому згідно з моєю
історією я щойно розповів вам історію, чи було
вам цікаво мене слухати, я
не впевнений у цьому, тому що я був досить
песимістичний і мене це не цікавило
, як ла-ла-ла-ла  la
мій вчитель, це нудно це не
цікаво, звичайно, коли у вас є лише
дієслова, ви нічого не розумієте, тому
давайте зробимо нашу розповідь цікавішою
та давайте додамо іменники, тож подивіться у
нас ранкові джинси бутерброд шкільні
уроки домашній фільм домашнє завдання та погано
ти скажеш мені Наталія, ти щойно розповіла
нам історію, використовуючи дієслова та
іменники, як ти прокинувся вранці або
я прокинувся вранці я одягнув
джинси я з'їв сендвіч
я пішов зі школи я мав уроки я повернувся
додому я подивився фільм я зробив собі
вдома  робота, і я знову пішов у бій, це
цікаво, мабуть, не так, що робить
нашу історію яскравою та цікавою,
це насправді прикметники чи прислівники,
давайте подивимося ще на один список
слів на початку Рон над NC, пощастило, що
вона жива курочка смачна ммм, це моє
улюблене  слова
це багато нінка швидко спочатку швидко
солодкий спокій дивовижний оригінальний краватка це
Tomlin фантастична фантастична школа коліна
Scola та пізні бізнеси, тому тепер ви можете
оновити свою історію, використовуючи ці слова,
виділені червоним, я дам вам 30 секунд, а тепер подумайте
про історію у вашому
не намагайся нічого, просто спробуй
у своїй думці створювати та складати речення добре, так що
30 секунд, хлопці, добре, так що ви готові
перевірити добре, ми не можемо перевірити насправді,
тому що я чую вас, але я можу поділитися
своїми ідеями з вами  тож давайте подивимось, я
прокинувся рано вранці, я одягнув свої
щасливі джинси, тому що я люблю їх, і
багато позитиву відбувається,
коли я одягаю свої щасливі джинси. Я з'їв
смачний сендвіч з бананами моя мама була
дуже креативною  сьогодні вранці, а
потім я швидко пішов до школи, я не
хотів спізнюватися, потім у мене були чудові
уроки з прекрасними вчителями, а потім
я повернувся додому, звичайно, я був трохи
втомлений, тому вирішив трохи відпочити, я
подивився  фантастичний фільм під назвою «Гаррі
Поттер», це насправді мій улюблений фільм,
і я любив його дивитися, потім я зробив
домашнє завдання до школи, а потім пізно
ввечері я ліг спати, тому порівняйте цю
історію, про
яку я тільки що сказав, що вона була першою,
яка використала на  дієслова, звичайно, різні,
тому, коли ви розповідаєте історію, не
давайте лише факти чисті факти, як я
прокинувся вранці я пішов до школи, я
мав урок
до побачення, це не буде
цікаво, додайте багато прикметників
слів, як дивовижний  фантастично пощастило
зробити вашу історію більш соковитою,
звичайно, О, ймовірно, це буде
негативно, але щоб додати трохи кольору до вашої
історії, насправді я маю до вас запитання,
чому нам потрібно пам’ятати історії і
чому нам потрібно читати книги  звичайно
це  допоміг нам запам’ятати багато речей,
ми вчимо слова з тексту з
розповідей, ми дізнаємося факти, тому це все для
практики нашої пам’яті, а зараз я проведу
з вами невеликий тест, тому підготуйте
зошит, але не беріть  сковорода, але
перш за все, ви збираєтеся подивитися
маленьке відео з десятьма словами, спробуйте
запам'ятати якомога більше слів, вам
просто потрібно запам'ятати слова, але
нічого не пишіть, просто заведіть руки
за спину добре, не ховайте руки  твої
руки йдуть так добре, тому що я
не люблю обман, добре, тому ти
подивись відео і спробуй згадати слова
готовий давайте йти піаніно
слон
Трек
пляшка
баскетбольний
стілець
ананас
собака
малює батут добре, це було
останнє слово, тепер я хотів би, щоб ти  щоб взяти
ручку або олівець і записати стільки
слів, скільки ви пам'ятаєте, будь ласка, не
перемотуйте відео Net Promoter tamazight
відео використовуйте свою пам'ять і спробуйте
записати слова, які я даю вам одну хвилину
[Музика]
[Музика  ]
добре, ви готові, так ле
Я запишу слова разом Я збираюся
написати слова, які я пам'ятаю, це також було
випробуванням для мене, тому я чесний
з вами,
тому перше слово, яке я пам'ятаю, це собака,
давайте запишемо його, якщо ви не
Нехай у вашому списку є слово собака, швидко
запишіть його добре, додайте їх до свого списку
розділіть місця Піско номер дві війни
вантажівка номер три війни крісло хм, я також
пам'ятаю пляшка, що це був за
батут,
добре, так піаніно, що буде наступне малювання, хм,
це важко  щоб зараз запам'ятати всі
слова ананас, то що ще нам потрібно ще
два слова допоможіть мені собака вантажівка крісло
пляшка батут фортепіано живопис
ананас баскетбол я не
пам'ятаю останнього слова, тож давайте разом перевіримо
і переглянемо відео знову піаніно
ephant
truck
[Музика]
пляшка
баскетбольний
стілець
ананас
собака
малює
батут, тому, як ви бачите, ми забули
слово слон, ймовірно, ви забули
різні слова, але зараз дуже
важливо мати список усіх 10
слів, і я б сказав, якщо ви j
звичайна людина Ієшуа є піхву ладіна
Тов ні мономер не видаляється занурений, як
прем'єр-партія здавалося visum рукав, тож це
було те саме для мене 7 було легко, тоді 8
було таким, і вони витратили
трохи енергії, щоб запам'ятати слово
баскетбол і  Я зовсім забув про
слона, і це нормально, я просто
звичайна людина і, мабуть, так само, як і
ви, багато людей пам’ятають усі 10
слів із самого початку, тому це
означає, що їхня пам’ять зараз працює дуже
добре, тому під час створення  історія
, нам дуже важко запам'ятати
слова тільки гірше, як ми зробили це у
відео, тому ми маємо їх у списку,
що ми будемо робити зі словами через
півгодини, ви забудете про них так,
ви забудете їх, тому давайте створимо  розповідь
, щоб запам'ятати слова, а також
потренуватися в оповіді, скажи, оскільки я
забув слова слон, це буде
мій головний герой слон, а собака
хотіла пограти в гру, тому вони
думали, хто прийшов грати, собака
любить грати  футбол, але слон
любить грати в баскетбол, тому давайте
позначимо речення від початку до
кінця, давайте помістимо їх у сюжеті в
рядок, щоб собака і слон це було
як перше речення, вони хотіли
грати в різні ігри собака любить
грати у футбол  але слон любить
грати в баскетбол, тому баскетбол
буде номером два, і у нас є такі
слова, як ананас малює фортепіано,
батут або стілець, а вантажівка
каже, що, ймовірно, продовжить
вантажівку, яку вони
вирішили піти на баскетбольний майданчик,
і для цього вони використали  вантажівка
вантажівка була повна різних пляшок,
я б сказав, що пляшки були наполовину заповнені, а
також було піаніно, тому їм було
важко подорожувати, але вони
досягли місця призначення, коли
вийшли на баскетбольний майданчик, вони побачили
там величезну картину, тому ми  мають слово
батут і ананас, тому, коли
вони побачили картину, вони вирішили,
чому ми збираємося грати в баскетбол, давайте
продовжимо малювати, давайте закінчимо
малювали, тому вони сіли на стілець і
почали малювати, звичайно, те, що було
на малюнку,
це був величезний батут, нарешті, коли
вони закінчили малювання, у них була
фантастична вечірка, вони пили багато
води з вантажівки і мали величезний
торт  форму ананаса, тож, як
ви бачите, я використав усі слова зі
списку у своїй історії, а
тепер давайте створимо вашу власну історію, і я
збираюся намалювати цю історію,
яка допоможе мені швидше запам’ятати, тому
придумайте свою власну  розповідь, яку я збираюся
намалювати для вас, і поки я малюю,
спробуйте запам'ятати використані речення,
я мовчу, я просто малюю, але ви
розказуєте речення, тож давайте
готові, давайте, щоб моя історія була
схожою на  це все тут
[Музика]
тому я готовий зі своїм зображенням, чи готові ви
до історії,
давайте разом перевіримо, скажімо, давайте просто
опишемо елементи, а потім  ми
розповімо історію, тому я назвав історію
слон і собака  пригода, як ви
бачите, це собака, це інший шрифт,
це символ футбольного
баскетболу,
це вантажівка.  ананас,
давайте перевіримо, чи використали вони всі слова
так, тож давайте знову розповімо історію
пригода слона і собаки, тож собака
та нульфікатор вирішили провести
день разом, вони хотіли пограти в гру,
щоб собака любила грати у футбол,
але слон  насправді любить грати в
баскетбол, тому вони вирішили піти на
баскетбольний майданчик, тому вони скористалися
вантажівкою, вантажівка була повна пляшок,
пляшки були наполовину заповнені водою,
там також було фортепіано, тому подорожувати було дуже
важко,
їм вдалося в той момент  вони прибули
на баскетбольний майданчик, вони побачили
там величезну картину, і вони подумали,
чому ми будемо грати в баскетбол, давайте продовжимо
малювати картину, щоб вони сіли на
стілець і продовжили малювати картину,
і там було  з величезним батутом на
картині, коли вони закінчили, вони влаштували
фантастичну вечірку, вони випили багато
води з вантажівки і у них був
величезний торт у формі
ананаса, тому це моя історія, і я
впевнений, що маючи картину в
вам буде легше
запам'ятати слова, якщо я приховаю
слова, а ви подивитеся на порожній
екран, чи можете ви назвати слова,
наприклад, подивіться на мене, я не дивлюся на
дошку і нічого не бачу
переді мною
слон розмова баскетбол вантажівка пляшки
фортепіано крісло живопис батут
ананас розмірне слова так,
мабуть, ви помітили, що цього разу
я назвав слова відповідно до
картинки Яніс швидкість личинка темний
Якунін ваша найнижча історія про мінерву,
мабуть, усі ви вже назвали
футбол, але це добре, це не
те слово зі списку, це лише
додаткове слово тут, тому ви вже
запам'ятали 11 слів, це дуже добре,
таким чином ви можете швидше потренувати свою пам'ять
s  o, хлопці, вашим домашнім завданням
буде створити свою власну історію, і для цього
ми будемо використовувати мій мобільний телефон. У
мене є додаток, у ньому є барвники
з картинками з картинками
, нам легше запам’ятати, тому що
таке  зараз це станеться. Я трясу телефон,
і кубики кидаються, коли я зупиняюся, я
бачу, що кістки готові для зображення, тому
я збираюся потрусити його знову, підготуйте
картинку, і ваше завдання полягатиме в тому, щоб
написати свою власну історію, використовуючи зображення
добре, і ви можете надіслати його моєму
чоловікові, щоб він перевірив школу Natalia dot
онлайн на gmail.com, готовий, і я
надішлю вам зображення, ми
маємо зображення для вас,
тому візьміть свій телефон, сфотографуйте або
призупиніть відео  запам'ятайте малюнки
зі слайда, а потім напишіть свою власну
історію, і вони чують дзвінок, це
означає, що нам потрібно припинити урок,
дуже дякую і побачимося наступного
разу, до побачення
[Музика]
ти